لا يبدو ان بولس جونسون مستعد لوضع
خلافاته مع ريشيسوناج جانبا فسناك كان اول
المستقلين من حكومه جونسون العام الماضي
محركا في ذلك الوقت انتخابات جديده بين
المحافظين اليوم يعود جونسون لممارسه ضغوط
على سوناك في خطوه اعتبرها البعض انها رد
اعتبار سوناك يواجه تحديا سياسيا بعد
استقاله جونسون ونائبين اخرين من مناصبهم
مثيرين بدورهم ثلاثه انتخابات تكميليه من
المرجح ان ينتزعها حزب العمال المعارض
جاءت الاستقاله على خلفيه تحقيق في
انتهاكات قيود كورونا والتي اعتبرها
جونسون محاوله متكرره للاطاحه به من
البرلمان كما اعتبر جونسون ان تاخير سوناك
الاعلان عن قائمه التكريم الخاصه به
وتغيير اسماء فيها اعتبره استهدافا سياسيا
له
اتهاماتنا اعتبرها مقربون من سوناك انها
وهميه وليست على لائحه اولويات السوناك
لم يغير ريشي تلك القائمه على الاطلاق
هناك لجنه لمجلس العموم عاده ما تتخذ كل
تلك القرارات ورئيس الوزراء لا يتدخل فيها
باي حال من الاحوال في بيان من الف كلمات
اتهم لجنه المزايا بانتاجها تقريرا قال ان
رائحه التحيز تفوح منه وتجبره على التخلي
عن منصبه بغض النظر عن الاسباب الرئيسيه
التي دفعت برج جونسون للاستقاله الا انها
قد تكون استباقا لنتائج تحقيق قد تقلل من
شانه السياسي او تسيء لسمعته بشكل يقود اي
فرصه مستقبليه له في عالم السياسه من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات